[Musique]
merci de nous accueillir de laisser 18
minutes
je vais commencer vous parler de mon
idée mais rendent pas régulier je vais
parler mais qui est de la lutte la
pensée collective je vous parlais a
brièvement deux mois jusqu'à ce que je
soutiens le midd évidemment je les pique
donc pas beau sport non pas ma vie
familiale mais l'ensemble de delhi
donc je présente très vite il marié
j'écarte j'ai trois enfants je suis
présidente de l'association je suis
organisateurs de l'événement national je
suis chef d'entreprise et je suis un
petit peu sportif sur les bords
plutôt orienté pour s'extraire du moins
alors c'est quoi là c'est quoi la course
extrême
l'histoire ne pas consommer mais diffus
minutes tout de suite tu vas pas toutes
les listes et mais je vais vous donner
quelques exemples pour qu'on puisse y
est vous projetez j'ai traversé la
vallée de la mort de 117 km sans
m'arrêter par 55° deux jours et 45 de
nuit j'ai couru 150 kilomètres sans
m'arrêter sur le cercle polaire pour moi
d'un doute
j'ai couru sur le voyage et corps et
sauvé sa normale j'ai traversé le sahara
à peu près dans tous les sens et course
voilà d'ailleurs non-stop en autonomie
ou autour de 200 250 km pour moi des
courses un peu plus longues on
500 600 800 200 km je cours
6000 mètres d'altitude j'ai gravi mondes
jaar où on prend ça c'est un petit peu
mon environnement
et puis donc vous l'aurez compris c'est
un petit peu pour oracle et gd piquer un
peu aux niches il ya quelques années par
rapport à l'image de mon territoire
je fais petite parenthèse moi j'ai vécu
dix ans à s'endetter c'est une
expérience merveilleuse aujourd'hui de
revenir sur ma terre natale mais
j'habite dans le loir et cher et je me
suis dit tiens je fasse quelque chose
qu'on l'aura cher et je vais surtout
prouver au delà du loir et cher que
problématique pour on à la limite c'est
pas l'état de la santé les budgets tout
ce qu'on veut c'est bon je me suis dit
je tente quelque chose de fou l'homme
aux yeux des autres ayant prouvé que
dans c'est parfaitement logique
parfaitement respectable parfaitement
possible et donc je suis à hugo
j'attaque un record du monde
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme en dehors du
monde intéressant dans ma discipline
on risque de mondial c'est trop facile
donc je vais prendre une discipline qui
n'est pas la mienne
j'aime lancer dans le trade et là je
découvre je suis pas un petit peu
orienté sur les pièces par lou je
découvre mais dans le téléthon mais
c'est évidemment mais je découvre que
l'entraînement il ya encore du monde qui
me semble fort sympathique parce que je
vais battre et que je le vois c'est
d'enchaîner dix ironman en dieu alors un
ironman pour ceux qui connaissent pas
donc c'est enchaîner 3 kg 28 de natation
avec 180 km de vélo et on termine par un
petit marathon 42 km de course est donc
le record du monde est de 10 10 en 10
jours et je me dis donc ça fait 226
romane et je me dis super si je le
double je veux le battre c'est sûr si
l'on ferme c'est nul
si j'en fais 20 matin c'était des
copains sportifs
si j'en fais 30 ça commence à être pas
mal
et en fait
je vais en faire 40 parce que 40 ça
pourrait bien ça me paraît vraiment
complètement démesuré pour prouver ce
que j'ai approuvé comme j'habite dans le
loir et cher j'ai limite je mixe plus
pour faute professionnelle
je peux penser retirant que jean-charles
41 vous aurez compris que cette vidéo
dans département
donc je j'annonce pour un coût que non
seulement je vais tenter mais j'ai
réussi à me défaire 41 normalement ce
que j'ai fait à l'été 2015 donc 9266 km
en 41 jours peuvent passage sur débattu
un deuxième jeu se développe en initiant
cessé d'en faire le plus dense et
retirant de 4 en un an
forcément ça aide voilà alors moi je
suis venu vous parler de d'une de mes
caractéristiques j'en ai plein comme
vous d'abord je suis normal
absolument comme vous et j'ai comme
caractéristique très clair dans mon
esprit que je n'ai pas pour habitude de
pensées comme les autres et que de près
cet important le premier c'est que j'ai
pas besoin de me démarquer énigmes
ferveur penser comme les autres et je
suis en opposition à une personne dans
les faits il apparaît assez
régulièrement passant systématiquement
heureusement que je suis je suis pas
forcément dans le mouvement ou par la
majorité
et cette fameuse majorité s'ils
s'appellent la pensée collective et moi
cette pensée collective c'est celle dont
je viens de vous parler aujourd'hui elle
me buttin me donne des boutons donc
j'adore me battre contre la pensée
collective juste juste par principe
targuait alors c'est quoi la pensée
collective bien évidemment ses pensées
ce que pense la majorité et que la
majorité pense si on est dans ce
mouvement là on est un peu dans la
pensée commune alors ça s'applique à
tous les domaines à ce constat je vais
parler de ma vie
brièvement avant et des domaines dgid
d'activité on peut en parler un
politique en son honneur en multi mme en
travail
en histoire en alors c'est quoi le sait
quoi mon problème avec moi c'est un an
et demi la consécutive je vais devenir
maman et demi s'est dit la finance ni
les étrangers si l'histoire reste est
dans l'air du temps vraiment mon ennemi
c'est la pente c'est le fait de penser
que l'être dans la pensée collective
parce que la pensée collective ça veut
dire quoi
la problématique c'est pas des de penser
comme la majorité aussi ça m'arrive la
problématique c'est intégrer ce que
pense la majorité dans ses aigus leur
décision si à un moment si nous permet
de faire un choix
on s'est dit ah ouais mais c'est tout le
monde pense à moi ça me pose un problème
ça me pose même un gros problème ça
s'appelle la subjectivité et comme je
suis un peu performeur pour m en tout
cas ambitieux ça j'hésite à le dire je
peux pas être rédigé sa lettre objectifs
actuels efficace c'est une nécessité par
ya encore pire
il ya ceux qui se disent à pacy qui
propose comme ça c'est bon choix
j'ai même pas me laisser achever un peu
c'est que je vais le fait trente ans la
majorité alors d exemple ça veut dire
quoi concrètement
dans une entrevue donnée quand on n'a
pas le temps c'est qu'on est débordé
besoin de montereau la disposition des
fois si on arrêtait facebook tu arrêtes
si on n'a pas pris des engagements qu'on
n'est pas capable de tenir ce courrier à
6000 mètres d'altitude
on le sait et on manque d'oxygène donc
c'est pas possible pas de chance moi je
les fais donc c'est possible
peut-être autrement mais c'est aussi des
femmes ont toujours froid
j'ai fait des expériences j'ai enlevé
des femmes dans l'himalaya
très beau tout reload 100% je leur ai
expliqué les techniques mais sans doute
trop chaud donc on peut effectivement se
tenir par défaut on a froid pour ce qui
est de plus en plus ça c est la pensée
collective vêtements de réflexes et
quadruplé à bord du monde évidemment
donc comme c'est n'importe quoi il ya
deux cas possibles dans la pensée
collective la pensée critique et le nie
pas que c'est complètement impossible
derrière tout ça c'est des plus gentils
les plus féroces envahir la force ait
ben idir est dopé moi j'ai déjà trouvé
un marathon mais vu comment j'étais
cassé quand je parle avec ses deux iron
man déjà dati laissez pas vous ça c'est
la pensée ça c'est la pensée collective
et puis combien d'ados qui vont
alimenter alors ça se trouver un
entraîneur qui m'a dit que j'ai entendu
un médecin a créé 17 est pas bon les
salaires rendre dans la pensée
collective
on va intégrer la ligne d autres sans
argument fiable intégrer la vue de la
vidéo que je prendrais devait arrêter
les côtes les autres écouté leurs
arguments
écoutez jeudi pendant une bonne
demi-heure écouté leurs arguments pour
prôner juger de la validité des
arguments
une fois qu'on a jugé qu'on a une valeur
sûre cette sur cet argument là savent où
le corps et le board a évidemment ils
l'ont fait pour pouvoir 9266 québec
revoit dans les anecdotes mais je veux
pouvoir dire j'ai un médecin une femme
qui m'a appelé un jour je ne serai pas
excéder les bonjour je suis médecin est
ce que vous allez faire c'est le port
n'est pas fait pour ça c'est
inadmissible je ne comprend pas qu'on
puisse se mettre dans un état pareil
pour territoire y compris avant mon la
tentative de
dumont et m'expliquer devant l'argentin
l'erc
c'est n'importe quoi je me mens danger
est que le rassemblement je vais même
bourré été vu au début la mariée j'ai
trois enfants qui a peut-être à tort
vous avez quoi comme hervé van daele
corps il est pote non mais en argument
d'accord bon alors je continue diplôme
de m'expliquer moi je suis prêt à
écouter tout commentaire pas de partis
clairement envie de lâcher mes enfants
et mon épouse
donc il faut qu'on me rapporte
désagréments justement où on apporte moi
je continue sur ma pensée parce qu'elle
me rassure franchement et je sais
comment je vais faire pour manger mais
prend et c est juste pour la petite
anecdote j'avais deux bilans sanguins
j'avais deux bilans sanguins par semaine
pendant mes quarante et un jours
c'est une page leblanc qui ont prouvé
quoi pour prouver qu au bout de 41 à
iron man j'étais plus en forme avant
d'avoir commencé
c'est ça la vie de contre la pensée
collective par mois je n'imaginais pas
que je n'ai pas objectivement j'imagine
est juste que j'en étais capable et
d'arriver dans le même état le port avec
la même sacrément bien fait si on s'en
sert si on est capable de se remettre en
question capable de s'ouvrir ce qu'on
voudrait faire là on peut progresser
dans tous les domaines et dans mon coeur
de la bienvenue et ça a été en plus
prouvé scientifiquement
j'ai envie de vous dire puisque comme
j'étais dopé pour les arrivées j'ai
aussi un bilan faim reste les anti
dopage alors a demandé dans les autres
pensées positives classique baroque on
est toute petite entreprise moi je suis
chef d'entreprise j'ai une toute petite
entreprise est pas si on les dit
entreprises autres avec des grands
groupes internationaux demandée car
utilisable
ces contrats d tout ça donc c'est pas
possible encore moins que les grosses
restitutions ben moi je fais la une
je dis cela mais je travaille avec
l'industrie automobile pharmaceutique
les centrales nucléaires avec les pleins
d'institutions et absolument aucun
problème
courir avec une déchirure musculaire
avec quelque chose de cassé avec une
hernie pleurales médicalement c'est
impossible et pourtant je les fais après
cette fois aucune fierté d'avoir fait
aucun plaisir non plus si cet esprit
d'art textile mais s'était passé n'était
pas mon ambition du mode du moment et
pourtant jeu léché des tatouages de
l'appliquer c'est pendant des centaines
de fidèles est c'est possible j'ai eu
une hernie globale d'un jour ça
m'arrivait aussi p
j'étais à 5005 1700 mètres d'altitude
j'étais en train de voir quelque chose
de magnifique voix j'ai fait une chute
je suis transpercé l'intestin il ya un
médecin qui était dans la course et qui
détectent une hernie globale et donc à
une li pronostic vital engagé
évacuation et béganne tu va m'expliquer
ce qui se passe en moi
comment est ce que je dois être vigilant
et tout ça j'ai fini l'étape j'ai couru
8h15 j'ai couru huit heures j'ai voulu
repartir le lendemain on m'a forcé j'ai
été évacué en france par mon assistance
je suis rentré j'ai acheté un billet
d'avion
j'entendais les balles j'ai fini lance
une pda de six allemands c'est là que ça
se sache et pour personnes alitées
agrément moi ça m'est déjà arrivé c'est
pourquoi on dit que d'être français ou
peu importe
et puis donne doit-on rappeler ce qui
s'est passé avec les analys mesurent ce
que peut entraîner la pensée collective
dans celle plus stupides alors pourquoi
les perverse la pensée collective
d'aller perverse parce que c'est à dire
que potentiellement ce qu'on nous
bassine ce qu'on vous raconte nous
explique c'est potentiellement faut
alors on peut pas avoir des réponses
surtout les déjà se poser des questions
ont cherché à creuser analysés ne serait
ce qu'à voir cette démarche là c'est
déjà refusé des plans même dans la
pensée
le deuxième effet pervers basse et le
monde évolue dans vos années j'avais
donc ça veut dire s'il était vrai un
certain temps bas ça n'est pas forcément
encore aujourd'hui je vous invite juste
à vous poser des questions et à chercher
l'objectivité en permanence parce qu'il
fait qu'on est tenté par la pensée
collective c'est qu'on est tous des
humains au fléau nos tares d'êtres
humains sont pas moches matin mais il
faut les accepter il prendra conscience
bas le confort on a envie de perdre son
confort
mais voilà ça peut nous ça peut orienter
h du mans et beat c'est un peu comme si
le françois ça veut dire bon confort
c'est quand même bien comme ça la
simplicité le moindre bout de l'effort
c'est un en ce moment où des
formes ou les autres c'est bien c'est
confirmé c'est plus compliqué donc si on
a des pensées qui nous arrange et qui
nous évite de faire de défense est quand
même le sentiment d'appartenance
évidemment c'est quelque chose qui fait
on va être très content d'être dans le
groupe i pour ce que mange pour ben ben
oui donc on est dans la pensée politique
la plante est jugée à la bbc je supporte
des autres ces spots radio nous ligue
auront évidemment et puis basiquement
d'histoire ancienne de notre humanité
c'est toujours bon d'être votée l'effort
d'acheter à manger me laisser tenter par
cette pensée qu était alors moi je n'ai
pas la pensée collective
j'ai joué et tout à l'heure j'ai pas
besoin d'être d'être de me sentir
différent j'ai besoin d'être en phase en
adéquation totale avec mes pensées et
j'ai surtout besoin de maîtriser le
sujet dans lequel dessus et que je sois
dans le sport d'entreprise en démarchage
commercial dans le bénévolat dans tout
ce que tout ce que je fais j'ai besoin
d'un sentiment de maîtrise ça c'est le
premier élément est le deuxième élément
fort moi c'est que j'ai horreur de 18
mois par définition quand je me trompe
un peu plainte
c'est de ma faute et même si c'est
quelqu'un que ces pentes attendant
une résidente deux associations qui se
plante fait une grecque c'est de ma
faute
j'étais pour expliquer quel point c'est
dangereux c'était une boîte il fallait
faire les produits ce que j'attendais
donc forcément il a joué aux deux choses
peuvent y penser bien y penser
six appartements vous pensez que
d'erreurs autour d'eux c'est pour la
chose de meta des bouddhas dans
l'entreprise voisins les étrangers je
sais pas forcément vous allez faire plus
d'efforts dans votre communication dans
notre comportement et vous avez plus
exigeants sur votre réflexion
l'organisation par la voie de
conséquence vous avez lutté contre cette
fameuse pensée collective
alors si mon avis est pas en phase
ça ne donne pas toutes ont quand même
n'arrive heureusement régulièrement même
d'être en phase explique ans la majorité
en tous cas je m'interdis d'être dans la
pensée collective va être dans une
valeur était de lui posant honnêtement
penser comme eux et puis doigts si ça ne
fait pas ça que j'aime pas ça me gêne
pas parce que je suis heureux même le
résistant ouvert ça faisait de moi parce
que je suis en confiance je suis en
confiance parce que j'ai fait des
efforts pour réfléchir à plein de choses
je pense avoir ni tout ce qui me font
d'objectivité pour avoir un avis et à
partir du moment où
j'ai réfléchi je suis objectif fonctions
moi si je suis confiant parce que c'est
pareil pour vous paerson sue performant
et surtout j'ai eu de poser des
questions ou les uns rubrique mon nom
j'ai réfléchi si on a réfléchi
le problème the ghost moi j'ai besoin
d'être bien dans ma peau route et de
réfléchir ça me
ça me donne une puissance totalement
folle je dirais même que c'est autorisé
ni plus ni moins de se sentir maître de
son destin et d'emploi dans 20 qui va
nous emmener
on sait pas où en tout temps mais non et
donc ce qui est sûr c'est que plus on
est sûr de soi furnes avance vite et moi
on se pose des questions et je vais
donner des exemples one la barre
énergétique et énergétique
c'est génial j'en manque var aux besoins
des étoiles là forcément une énergie dr
c'est un truc de dingue pour d'un mois
sur la lande match je mange des crêpes
mange des pâtes blanches des voyages
d'un faux mais chez ce que je mange
c'est pourquoi j'aurai 20 je sais quel
moment à quel rythme je suis dans la
maîtrise j'ai une confiance totale
les autres nous regardent avec des yeux
d'elsa ou interrogations je sais
pourquoi j'en suis là je sais pourquoi
j'ai fait ces choix là je sais que ça va
marcher
j'ai une confiance totale en moi parce
que j'ai pas je j'ai réfléchi et
objective deuxième exemple pour terminer
évidemment quand il fait très froid
qu'on se couvre et ben non pas moi
évidemment j'ai pas de caractéristiques
physiques qui font que le froid comme
vous tous non j'ai juste un trip ulliel
la problématique longtemps et je me
dirais décroche juillet sur l'everest en
fait c'est je suis vachement mieux
courir en short et en mai au ski c'est
bizarre je m'amuse à doubler encore des
de sa carence à des valeurs l île voire
agaçant courant en sortent leur maillot
j'avoue j'ai un petit plaisir quand même
j'aime ce que ces quelques règles
quelques rêves d'héroïsme à celle des
dégâts mais en fait pourquoi je suis
bien au choix j'arrive à bout et j'ai
même pas qu'ils seraient là on sait
juste que j'ai une dépense énergétique
qui est importante c'est juste que ça me
permet de réguler et c'est juste que je
sais que si je suis trop couvert et que
je transpire
non seulement je vais être très mal visé
mais en plus je prends un risque si j'ai
vu l'unité sur moi étaient je m'arrête
je suis sur le cercle polaire je suis m
d'altitude et en tant que ça dure pas
longtemps dans l'eau - wendel ça fait
pas bon ménage et juste d'avoir un
échange thermique d'avoir réfléchi et
c'est problématique là ça m'a permis de
manière côté je partirai comme ça je
suis confiant c'est pourquoi je le faire
et je sais que ça va marcher et garang
sûr j'ai un petit blouson un pull quand
même tendance à cadeaux et quand je
m'arrête je pense voilà et je terminerai
donc sur une maxime de paulus que
j'adore mais que je pense que résume
parfaitement mon propos je n'ai pas
compris que j'étais fier qui disait
quand on voit ce qu'on voit et quand on
entend ce qu'on entend on a raison de
penser ce qu'on pense balla et ben
maintenant à vous de jouer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]